signori miei se ma il terzo e ultimo
episodio di the passion
spero che il video vi piaccia e sono
finale coi fiocchi
un bacino buona visione allora è
cambiato un po tutto qui teoricamente
dovrei andare a prendere una boccia del
vino non dove ci stanno dei vestiti
dentro non dovrebbe non devo andare in
una taverna però fa niente non so da
dove mi sta cagando sotto ma fa niente
si papato è la finiamo questo serpente
gigante io l'ho solo un vestito che ha
vestito con la corona le scarpe tutto
però fa niente va bene anche il serpente
però che non ci buttavano mica la
bambina da milano era 600 i genitori di
merda fase scassata se scassata cioè
l'ultimo pezzo ce l'ho l'ho trovato bene
ho finito posso uscire per noi non ci
siamo infatti in questi due metri
in questo metro non me ne frega niente
via fuori dalle balle
ce l'ho fatta raga posso finalmente
aprire l'ultima porta quella del primo
episodio vediamo che succede
sono un po cacato sinceramente però si
sa ma potremo sempre scoprire le cose
belle tipo già parte bene già alla luce
farfalla che una bellezza
ho detto già la luce sfarfalla che
allora la mia pazienza non esiste quindi
ultimo vi guarda
nella vita inculati ma qualcosa mi dice
che non me ne vado di la labilità fa
schifo sono entrato la porta chi da
parte di una porta che si chiude non si
chiude la porta non si chiuda portami
questa via via via via via via via via
via via via via via via via va bene va
bene va bene va bene va bene ok tutto a
posto come se non stesse succedendo
niente fa niente chiusolo agli ospiti
comunque potresti tornare a casa
torniamo un altro giorno che dici porca
vacca se stanze chiuse
mi sto pagando di sopra la cosa brutta
ragazzi che tutto questo mi sono accorto
solo alla fine che aveva una persona
dietro non come all'inizio preso nel
camper incredibile va bene trovava
qualcosa da fare la tua vita
basta guarda i video dei controtempo
basta a questa porta però c'è se per
caso una porta non si apre io sono morto
morte punto chissà se scegliendo fra le
completa
a caso fa niente la sento cancellano
aiuto è sempre vicino aiuto aiuto
basta che fastidio
dateci un taglio sta roba porca vacca
basta avete rotto basta ed ora che tiro
spallate le porte
mamma mia come questa parte mi do da
fare c'è un ascensore cori aiuto
vai a piano terra più a terra parola
lattico piano terra chiudere la porta ma
bravo bravo fluida con le mani quindi
dopo le mani di fila con le mani con le
mani a posto
cioè non posso un cazzo non si chiude si
chiude in 3 2 1 si chiude in 3 dr1 si è
legato né secco bocca però il resto è il
muro che non vi piace
chiudi la porta ci vuol dire la porta
anzi chiudi la porta
chiudi la porta
[Musica]
ecco tutto a posto tutto a posto
bastava essere calmi nei momenti di
panico si risolve tutto con la calma e
la fermezza medi karma sanzione sono
arrivati molto bene un'altra porta che è
quella di prima ovviamente posso entrare
in questa fottutissima porta che sono
due ore per ti prego
ho capito st porta non si raggiunge a
senza andando dove vai vai vai vai vai
tranquilla finché va via
tutto a posto
rolle nota ma forse non sapeva come a
tutti per il culo perché due ore all ha
permesso vita nuova
quindi
a ci fa vedere di canto scommetti
no non ce la fa vedere
questo è il tipo l'inizio del gioco sono
sempre alla fine del tè ha fatto deleghe
che canta a passo alzarmi
tutto a posto no pensavo si fosse messo
tutto a posto e invece da io che ci ho
creduto
vabbè permesso che peccato ero contento
papa quando a casa ma dorme tornasse
adatta mi manca anche a me però se non
mi chiudi in testa il soffitto è meglio
ma te fatto bene il suo gioco tra
l'altro chef attualmente benissimo sono
la bambina ok c'è san babila deve vivere
da sola col padre un macello
come può la mamma averla abbandonata con
un padre così ma poi
aveva questa soffriva pure di ansia
mammamia guarda l'azione ansiolitica
[Musica]
certo quella nun se inseribile c'è lei
che vive col padre che prendere
pastiglie per l'anno
terribile nord
chissà
e parla un po di ansia secondo me
sta succedendo ragazzi a che punto siamo
arrivati in stagione
mi manca
o mamma no non lo è si sta roba
a miano mi hanno diagnosticato devo
andare nel reparto psichiatrico perché
sono andato dice il padre andato di
testa a rho alla figlia mia figlia non è
lunatica ok quindi il dettaglio che mi
manca il perché questo gioco è stato
bannato da steam palla è ok siamo nel
momento mind faq del gioco non si
capisce una sega libro che succedono a
sto facendo harakiri vivo eccoci tutti i
sei persone sembrano cioè se ma che
stiamo facendo yoga ed ata sono anime
povere anime che stanno soffrendo
[Musica]
far finta di niente proseguire devo
trovare mia figlia dice che credo sia
questo il succo del discorso c'è una
porta
cosa dovremmo fare l'abbiamo fatta
abbiamo passato soprattutto quel porto
per persone che non è male
cos'è che vedi un albero già vedo
proprio quello è l'albero della vita
ora devi guardare dentro te stesso vabbè
messo a parlare dentro me stesso e
questo lo devo fare suo il tuo io
interiore che sono pieno di averi che
sono il padre perché queste sono le le
penne che io utilizzo per scrivere sullo
scrittore a vini vero il padre finora
l'ho capita fine gioco ottimo ottimo
capire la fine gioco molto bene
quindi questo è il mio io interiore
vorrei fare anch'io un viaggio da
lorenzo all'interno del mio corpo e
arrivando a una porta o ancora una
chance di salvarla
vai avanti ok just a parente
ok va bene salvaro mia figlia indovinare
quale tra tutte queste
e non so capelli senso
[Musica]
sante mantra
in media
ore 15 su raidue si nota quindi alla
fine hanno fatto le scale mica roba è
che ce ne sono due
devo proprio salvare quella giusta
secondo me non è lei però governo c'è un
cucchiaio coprendo bene
no non lo fare nuovo fare non lo fare
però lo faccio io ma che schifo mi sono
staccato un ottimo ma io no
ecco cos'è che ha fatto parlare questo
gioco da sting che mi sono staccato un
occhio
a dirlo e mezzo del nuovo capitolo sai
come si suol dire amico mio occhio non
vede cuore non 9 questo invece secondo
me fa un po più male perché la tra un
cucchiaino questo è un po più lo so c'è
un po più peso poi non lo so per carità
perché non mi intendo di robert però
ficcatelo dove voi alla mia lingua
ok per restaurare la voce angelica di
mia figlia
va bene già il fatto che si sentirà
possa fare una lingua fa schifo non la
posso tagliare ceramica strappa via
l'altra figlia
deve fare malissimo e la madonna
se ciò che proprio non sa proprio felice
una lingua no nel senso
occhio però basta basta giochiamo anche
la mano c'è nel senso il l'orologio
l'orologio l'orologio alexa non ho detto
niente stai zitta che è un momento
difficile testata su cosa altra testata
ancora un'altra
la posta tra lingue occhi mani e testate
mia figlia posto o restaurato tutto
tutto a posto tutto bene ma la lingua
cielo vado al massimo vento come la
morte ma cosa è successo
una freccia nel la porta a welkom vela
beh se c'è la cosa mi sto capendo più
niente
mia figlia è viva o no cos'è successo
spiega mi parla di qualcosa ad un
tulipano passano davanti a settembre 29
un giorno di pioggia mamma non è ancora
tornata a casa
mi manca provano piangere quindi quando
mi trattengo il mio petto inizia a farmi
male
un giorno anche il mio respiro ha
iniziato a ridare problemi papa dice che
non guarderemo più i dottori e domani
andremo a vedere il mentore woods e
tutto andrà bene ma ma credo che il mio
papà non sapevo me farmi sentire meglio
e successo tutto questo a parte le
canzoncine la bambina in salvo o no
voglio saperlo ho giocato tre ore
bianco
[Musica]
readers la bambina è salva credo bella
canzone no quindi ho salvato mia figlia
ha apposto importante questo e andiamo
li fanno soffrire sti titoli definire
così finisce bene se finisce addio addio
ti ringrazio e scajola
ciao e voi ci motiva comunque bello
molto bello molto significativo horror
fino a un certo c'è horror però me lo
immaginavo un molto più c'è allora io ho
visto il gioco passato da steam
ok facciamolo subito questo era devotion
molto carino
spero che vide vi sia piaciuto signori è
tutta la serie miniserie lasciato un bel
mi piace iscritti al canale la
campanella va schiacciata perché non si
schiaccia la sola che rimanete
aggiornati i suoi video che escono come
sempre ragazzino ci vediamo al posto
lido per ragazzi